- Welcome back, y'all.
(audience applauding)
We're here with the cast
of the new Netflix movie,
"The Bubble",
(audience applauding)
Maria Bakalova, Iris
Apatow, Keegan Michael Key,
the movie's writer and
director, Judd Apatow,
and Leslie Mann,
(all applauding)
my partner in crime.
So "The Bubble" is the story
of the making of a
blockbuster disaster movie,
so we thought it'd be fun
to see how well we know
our blockbuster disaster movies,
with a game called, 'cause we're clever,
"Double Trouble in the
Rubble with The Bubble".
(Leslie laughs)
(upbeat music)
♪ Double Trouble in the
Rubble with the Bubble ♪
(audience applauds)
So the teams are...
This is the winning one,
this is Leslie and me,
uh-huh, and then the others,
(Leslie chuckles)
Judd and Keegan Michael,
(all laughing)
and then Iris and Maria.
Good luck.
(all laughing)
We need a host, so, God are you there?
- [God] I am Kelly, how you doing girl?
- Okay, well, the world
might be coming to an end,
but just could you help us with the game?
- [God] Well, I certainly can.
Hey, all you beautiful people,
and also Keegan.
(all laughing)
I'm just playing Keegan, I'm just playing.
So here's how the game works.
I'm gonna ask a trivia question
about a disaster movie,
and if you know it, you buzz in.
And steals are allowed by the way.
Now, if you're right,
you're gonna get a chance
to double your points
with a bonus question.
Now, if Judd and Keegan, or Iris and Maria
beat Kelly and Leslie,
their photos will go up
on the wall of champions
who beat Kelly Clarkson.
(audience clapping)
That's my favorite.
- Hate it.
- [God] And I will be very
happy if that happens.
- Whatever, God.
- Now if...
Whatever to you, Kelly.
Don't talk back to me girl.
(all laughing)
- [Kelly] You know me better than that.
- [God] Now, if Leslie helps Kelly win,
a special tribute will
be made in her honor.
So here we go, here's the first question.
(suspenseful music)
In this disaster movie,
Brad Pitt is up against
super fast zombies.
(device ringing)
- Oh, I got it. I got it.
I got it.
- This one...
- "World War Z".
- [God] "World War Z".
(audience cheering)
That is correct.
- [Kelly] (mumbles) I knew that one.
Now I'm freaked out at
when they hit it. (grunts)
- [God] Now, Iris and Maria,
here is a bonus question for you.
True or false?
Did Brad Pitt become a zombie
at the end of the movie?
- He didn't, false.
- [God] That is correct.
(device dings)
It is false.
(audience applauds)
- [Leslie] Are they gonna beat us?
- Good girl, Iris.
- [Kelly] Your daughter's good.
- Good job.
- My God...
- [God] He may be one now,
'cause that man never ages.
(audience laughs)
Okay, here's your next question.
- If we get beat by your kid, I blame you.
(Leslie laughs)
- [God] In this disaster movie,
to save earth from an asteroid,
Bruce Willis and Ben
Affleck have to drill.
(device rings)
- "Armageddon".
(device dings)
- [God] It is "Armageddon".
(audience applauds)
(Kelly cheers)
(clapping continues)
(Kelly mumbles)
- [God] And now,
Kelly and Leslie for double the points,
who plays Bruce Willis' daughter?
(device ringing)
- Oh, no, wait.
No, that's us.
That's us.
- [Maria] I'm sorry.
- It's our turn, right?
(all laughing)
- [God] That's you, miss.
- Liv Tyler.
Liv Tyler.
(device dings)
You'd steal, you'd steal.
Liv Tyler.
(all laughing)
- [God] That is right. Liv Tyler.
- Hey, but hey Keegan,
join in any time now-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
You got it. You got it.
- [God] All right.
Here's your next question.
In this film, Benedict Cumberbatch
uses ancient mystic powers-
(device ringing)
- Please.
- "Doctor Strange".
(device dings)
- [God] It is "Doctor Strange" .
- Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- [Kelly] It's my favorite.
He's my favorite.
- Yeah.
- [God] And now, here's the big moment.
Judd and Keegan, here's
your bonus question.
How did Doctor Strange
get injured in that movie?
- Oh, how does he get injured?
Oh, a car accident.
(device dings)
- [God] That is correct.
(audience applauds)
It was, a car accident.
- Nicely done.
(Leslie clapping)
Nicely done.
- Thank you.
- [God] Okay, here's your next question.
(suspenseful music)
In this film,
A T-Rex eats a guy on a toilet-
(device ringing)
- No, she did it before!
(Leslie laughing)
She did it before.
- (clapping) "Jurassic Park".
(device dings)
- [God] It is "Jurassic Park".
(audience applauds)
All right, now, here is your bonus-
- Oh, am not waiting now, man.
- [God] Here is your bonus.
Here's your bonus question, okay?
- Oh, that's perfect.
- [God] Now, I want you to
finish this Jeff Goldblum line
from the movie, and I
want you to let me know
what the last word is, of
this Jeff Goldblum line.
(Iris and Maria whispering)
'Yeah, but your scientist
was so preoccupied
with whether or not they could,
that they didn't stop to think if they...'
- (gasps) Oh, I know it.
I know it.
- [God] Blank.
(Kelly exclaims)
- What?
(device buzzes)
- No, can we steal?
Can we steal?
(Leslie laughs)
- [God] You can steal.
(device ringing)
I'll let you do it.
- 'Should'.
(device dings)
- [God] It is 'should'.
That's right.
(audience applauds)
- [Michael] But then, shouldn't we be-
- I know you should, but-
- When we're stealing-
- Guys, you haven't.
(all laughing)
- [God] I'm making up the
rules as I go along here.
- Okay.
- [God] All right, this
is the final question.
Here it is.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [God] In this movie, Scarlett Johansson-
(device ringing)
plays a woman,
- "Black Widow".
- [God] It is "Black Widow".
(device dings)
(audience applauds)
- All right.
- [God] And so there it is...
- Thank you.
- That's good.
- That was a really good movie.
- Yeah.
- [Iris] Really good movie.
- What does that mean now, God,
or what is happening?
- [Maria] Oh.
- [God] Oh, but Kelly, you still won!
(bright victorious music)
- What!
- [God] This is unbelievable.
- Wait, how?
- [God] I'm looking at the points here.
You still won, because you
got the bonus question.
- How did we do it?
(Leslie cheering)
How did we do it?
(audience applauding)
Look at him, he's leaking. (laughing)
- [God] Yeah, sure.
- The game is beyond me.
- [God] Just making this up as I go.
- I feel like God is an employee of yours.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God, I don't know how we won,
but we won and God said so.
So...
(audience applauding)
Thanks for helping me win.
Last time we played a game,
we were on opposing teams.
- Yes.
- On a Hollywood game though.
- I think we do better
as a team.
- As a team.
- Yes. Yes.
In honor of Leslie helping me win,
our show will arrange a special tribute.
We don't know what that is yet,
'cause we didn't know
if we were gonna win,
obviously my staff had no faith
that I was going to win
(all laughing)
so they didn't think of something,
but it will be special,
it'll be so special.
Thank you everyone for playing.
(all applauding)
- Everyone, "The Bubble" is on Netflix,
its very funny, check it out.